welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two thirty six thirty two
twenty eight eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight Josh and
Georgia you're on the bench barrel go
for Josh I've been a quick question
aren't there laws already in place that
prohibits the destruction of national
monuments yes yes there are yes there
are federal laws in place that prohibit
the destruction of federal monuments
there are state laws in place to
prohibit the vandalism of state and
local monuments all that stuff already
exists correct you are the problem of
course is that no one will enforce those
laws and this is happening largely at
the local level we saw this in Milwaukee
of course in Milwaukee and in Madison
they basically are just allowing people
to to knock over monuments at will we
saw this in in Washington DC it's
terrible I mean it does demonstrate and
when you have local authorities who are
willing to allow lawlessness to run
rampant lawlessness runs rampant that's
why when President Trump issued like a
new executive or hidden ad issue a new
executive order that was utterly
unnecessary it is already against the
law to do the kind of stuff that he is
now prescribing by law but you know
anything that signifies that the
president is going to stand up to this
is probably a good thing for him at this
point Josh it's it's a source of high
incidence to those of us who are law
abiding it's a source of high irritation
that basically people are being allowed
to go out on the streets and just rip
down public monuments I don't care what
the my minutes I really don't like I
don't like some of these monuments I
think some of these monuments are bad I
don't mind if we get rid of some of the
monuments through Democratic vote but
I'm not for lawless mobs running through
the streets tearing things down in the
wall abiding Society that's not how
democracy is supposed to work there's a
monument for Alicia Garza they probably
tear that down too yeah that's right I
mean one of the things that many of the
local authorities have decided probably
is you know better to let these people
tear things down than to have an armed
confrontation over the statute they
don't want the optics of defending a
Confederate statue and then violence
occurring but guess what you don't get
to pick the property that you defend you
don't the larger principle which is that
mobs don't go around running around
tearing down property it is not up to
you to decide which one of those statues
is worth defending it is up to the
people of that state to decide which of
those monuments are worth defending and
this is just it's ugly and it's stupid
and it's optical its optical garbage
from our politicians who have neither
stones nor intestinal fortitude to stand
up for rule of law and when your
authorities won't stand up to rule of
law there's sort of a outside-inside
game that is played very often in
politics Josh and it's something has
been written about my Fred Segal he
wrote an entire book about the decline
of America's major cities in the 1960s
and 70s there was this outside-inside
game in which politicians would
basically cooperate with outside
agitating groups and those outside
agitating groups would threaten violence
Marion Barry used to do this in DC and
and then they would threaten you know
unrest and then the politician did well
I guess I got to give them what they
want so we don't get violence and unrest
and that is not the way to run a city
that is not law-abiding behavior it
really is quite terrible Josh I
appreciate the call tarek in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania you're on the bench Peter
I'll go for it Sarah hi how you doing
I'm just calling to ask you do you think
this country is gonna keep doing crazier
as we get closer towards the election I
can't imagine it won't I mean I kept I
keep feeling like even a few months ago
I can't really get crazier than this and
wrong that I was it's like the biblical
portion of Deuteronomy that each night
you're gonna go to sleep thinking it
can't be crazier than this in the
morning and then every morning are gonna
wake up and go I wish it was only as
crazy as last night that that is that is
where we are right now you know we are
not even up on the election yet I mean
there's still another what four and a
half months until the election it's
gonna get worse it's gonna get
absolutely worse because the Democrats
have in an interest in chaos the media
have an interesting cast I will say that
the media in particular are truly awful
on this sort of stuff I mean they just
lie about what it's going on they egg on
the protesters they they use phraseology
that is designed to justify horrible
behavior the media as I've said before
they basically become Jake Gyllenhaal
movie Nightcrawler there's a movie
called Nightcrawler came out a few years
ago in which Jake Gyllenhaal plays the
sociopathic photojournalist who goes
around taking pictures of car crashes
and then selling them to local news in
like the late 1980s early 90s and then
he realizes wait a second I can actually
make more money if I help stage these
things if I like get people to crash and
burn and then I take pictures of it I'm
the first person on the scene always I
don't have to compete with anybody else
the media are now a player in the
creation of the chaos and that is
extraordinarily extraordinarily
dangerous
yeah it's pretty crazy I hear what
you're saying just uh yeah I'm just
curious to see what's gonna happen next
months at this point just taking it the
writers have really let out the
storylines out of the bag I will say the
writers of this season of this 2020
season of Trump the show I feel like
they just took all the old storylines
out of the file cabinet and just threw
them all in there at the same time with
a pandemic we've got race riots guys
turning down statues we've got Joe Biden
being accused of sexual it's not like
all of the things came out at exactly
the same time and I sort of fear what is
coming next Eric I appreciate call
Andrew how long all the way from our
northern neighbors in Canada has gone
Andrew and I just kind of question is
that
Michael Knoll said that in order to get
through this we're going to need to kind
of go through the matrix right we're
gonna need to go right to the end we
can't turn back we need to go all the
way through you think that's going to be
this upcoming election or do you think
that's going to be four years from the
election like we're gonna need to go a
full second term with all this crazy
media foolishness for everyone's talking
about sides that are now so I think that
what is likely to happen the only way
that we return to moderation and this is
a very dark vision of the future
prepare yourself I think the only way I
know we return to anything that like
moderation is Joe Biden and the
Democrats sweep into power at the end of
this year which is unfortunately
becoming increasingly likely we get two
years of absolute garbage and the
American people like I've had enough of
this by the way that's exactly what
happened in 2008 right Barack Obama ends
up winning 70 million votes and the idea
is that the Democrats have an
unbreakable unshakable majority in the
house they have a supermajority in the
Senate and they have a filibuster-proof
majority in the Senate and they will be
able to just go from here to from
victory to victory and then they push
Obamacare and within two years the house
is Republican again and within two years
the Republicans are moving toward a
majority in the Senate I think something
very likely to have that that is a high
likelihood because right now basically
the anti-trump sentiment is driving the
Democrats but a cohesive program inside
the Democratic Party like the only
cohesive body inside the Democratic
Party are the radicals the American
people are not signing up for that and
parties routinely missmiss estimates
their mandate they overestimate their
mandate a George W Bush famously said
this in 2004 right he won reelection and
then he said well I think I have a
mandate
and the mandate was that he was going to
be able to push Social Security
privatization and immigration reform got
neither of those things and then he got
shellacked in 2006 in Congress I could
easily see something like that happening
coming up um but you know as far as the
left mattering if Trump wins the left is
absolutely not gonna moderate if Trump
wins then the argument is going to be
that you guys we nominated the moderate
what we won with Joe Biden the dead
moderate and he lost so now we need to
move even further to the left it's no
matter how you slice it I think the next
few years are going to be increasingly
ugly well thanks I appreciate it yeah
there's some murasa tea for you hope you
enjoyed that with your morning coffee
market illinois you're on the bench
bureau shell go for it mark hey Ben are
you doing um I was curious do you think
Hillary will wind up being indicted and
do jail time no III think this has been
litigated I think that she will never be
indicted I do not think she will do jail
time James Comey let her off the hook
and because Jim's coming let her off the
hook she's not gonna be reprosecution
unless she's committed some additional
crimes or new evidence comes to light
neither of which is is the case it is an
unfortunate truth of life that Democrats
are far more willing to use the official
mechanisms of the law in order to get
their friends out of prison and target
their enemies and I know people are
gonna say Mike Flynn here except that
Mike Flynn was actually targeted
unfairly by the Obama Justice Department
and the Obama FBI so they're a bunch of
holdovers there who are pushing the
flint prosecution on the basis of a very
very slim read mark appreciate the call
jeremy in illinois you're on ben shapiro
show before Jeremy
yes Ben I'm I haven't listened listen
every day and I'm a school teacher and
at a local district in Illinois and
we're being inundated with a lot of
bloke leftist books specifically white
fragility and we're being asked to read
those to help better understand our our
implicit bias and you understand the
racial superiority I guess they're
trying to say within our diverse school
about 40% African Americans 6% white my
question is how would you recommend like
going about maybe from not promoting but
maybe
talk to the school district about you
know what the negative aspects of
promoting these kind of ideology are
within a school that is is that versed
and then we're semi-rural so we have
conservatives but I'm definitely in the
minority within the school as a
conservative within the Union and things
of that nature
how could I better approach these ideas
with my school district or within my my
building my colleague so white fragility
is legitimately one of these stupidest
and worst books ever written it is a
horrible book it is a horrible book in
fact I have a video that's coming out
this weekend on YouTube in which I goes
in detail through white fragility it's a
long video I go through the problems of
it the stupidity of it the arrogance of
it the self-centeredness of it however
well I recommend that you send my video
to your school board I feel like that
will have very little impact on your
school board considering the
constituency of the school board instead
I would said them there's an episode of
a podcast called block and cancelled by
a couple of people on the Left Jessie
single who you story from New York
Magazine and Katy her cycle you strive
for the Seattle stranger deconstructing
the book white fragility and doing an
interview with an african-american woman
I believe who sat through the diversity
training put forward by Robin D'Angelo
and it just exposes how terrible and
cultish this book is the real question
here is what exactly are these programs
designed to do and the real answer for a
lot of school districts is its to
alleviate accusations that they're
racist so much of this is about saying
you can't call me racist I assigned
Robyn D'Angelo to everybody I mean this
is why so many businesses do diversity
training it's not because they are
deeply committed to the causes of Robyn
D'Angelo it is because they believe that
they are then protecting themselves from
liability you can't claim that we are
systemically racist we spent tens of
thousands of dollars to bring in this
white fragility author in order to speak
to our people about why they are racist
and now here you are calling us racist
they're trying to by absolution and
that's what these school districts are
really trying to do but I mean are they
the real question is are they convince'
ballif they're convinced about and
frankly a simple read of the book should
be enough to demonstrate how stupid the
book is I mean it's a really really bad
book but if they are not I have a
feeling that your school district is not
really into the cause of promoting
racial equality and racial understanding
they're much more into the cause of
covering their own asses by assigning a
bunch of pablum nonsense that basically
suggests that one group in America is
responsible for this all suffering
of anybody who's a member of another
group in America and socioeconomics
doesn't matter another that matters the
only thing that matters is race it's a
single factor analysis which of course
is the worst kind of sociological
analysis I totally agree with that and I
guess I can have a second question about
the 16:19 project I'm a history teacher
to you I don't really teach us history
but I teach more like world history and
geography but with that like is there a
way to you know maybe you know I don't
know maybe approach that as well within
that book or is all is that a separate
issue all together um no I mean this is
this is definitely you know part of the
broader rubric I mean the broader rubric
here is that America is endemically evil
the white did that white systems like in
she literally says it's Robins Angelo in
her book and so does Nicole Hannah Jones
by the way things like individualism and
meritocracy are in fact simply guised
forms guys dividuals visages of white
supremacy
Nicole Hannah Jones has a piece today in
the New York Times Magazine about
slavery reparations in which she equates
slave catchers with people engaging and
stop and frisk in New York City a policy
that by the way disproportionately saved
black and Hispanic lives the the endemic
stupidity of all of this is perfectly
obvious to anyone I mean other Pulitzer
Prize winners have critiqued Nicola
Hannah Jones's work and pointed out
there's so much with the 16:19 project
that it's just bunk in fact I have a new
book coming out how to destroy America
in three easy steps in which I devote at
least a couple of chapters to talking
about the perverse view of history
pushed forward by the far left it's it's
incredibly to interest and again it is
part of the same worldview that
worldview is America is endemically evil
that everything bad in America is
actually what makes America special so
what makes America special is not our
freedom and liberty which are outliers
in human history what makes America what
America is is all of the evil things
about America and this is sort of like
an optical illusion right it's the
optical illusion where is it a vase or
is it two human faces right it's that
optical illusions you look at America as
what like what's the background and what
is the story is the background human sin
cruelty evil malice colonialism
imperialism racism and slavery is that
the is that the common background of
human history from which America stands
apart because America stands out right I
mean America is different than that over
time or is the background of human
history wonder and joy and in
and Rousso lien Rousso nyan new worlds
in which everybody lives in peace and
harmony with the birds and the animals
and then what really sets America apart
is its cruelty and its malice and it's
evil and I think it's pretty obvious
which one of these is true and which one
of these is false but the version that
is false has gained a lot of critters in
recent years as we have decided that the
common state of man is is decency and
good and yet we are we are all placed in
Chains the men are born free and then
placed in Chains and Rousseau suggested
a more appreciative and Jeramy
appreciate the call